my next guest as well the two-time Big
Ten Coach of the Year here's a Badgers
113 and one last season currently ranked
seven in the preseason coaches poll
he is the born and raised in Madison
Wisconsin
the coach of Wisconsin Paul Chryst how
are you coach I know I already tell you
doing I am doing fine
what are your ticket requests for every
game you know I'm pretty lucky one of my
wife's deals with it all so I don't have
to do anything but okay
a lot of them have have I've had tickets
for a while so it's it's not bad so they
don't ask for upgrades to get closer
then okay so they're you so it's all
handled you don't have to worry about
that sort yeah I'm lucky there I don't I
don't really do a whole lot during the
seasons outside of the job so it's just
I'm pretty lucky the job what does the
job look like two weeks before the
beginning of the season on a college
campus for you you know it's still you
know in the middle of training camp
which is different you know I think the
last couple years training camps taking
on a little bit of different feel to it
but it's still fun it's fun to get going
you know the the kids spend so much time
in the winter and then you have spring
ball and summer training but they get
into fall camp and and get going it's
it's a good time and a fun time and and
you know the group that we've got you
know they like I like playing and they
like each other so so each day is fun to
be around them and just trying to make
sure that we're doing everything we can
to to get ourselves ready for the opener
we are Dabo Swinney on earlier this week
and he said that college football your
level is the only spot and in any level
of sports in America that does not have
some sort of madness or Jamboree or
training camp or anything like that
where you get to scrimmage against
somebody and write what you want to have
something like that you know what
there's a it's a it's a weird feeling
when you you know that first game you
just you want to find out about guys and
netting you know we've I've been around
it enough we you don't know any other
way right but it's I were just talking
about with some of the players were on
the field yesterday and just
no it'd be kind of nice to find out and
get to know but you know I don't think
it's gonna change right now so don't
spend much time thinking about it it is
what it is as coaches say okay yeah sure
now very rarely do I see offensive
linemen as cover boys but yours are in a
regional cover for your area for I guess
the Upper Midwest there they are the
offensive linemen of the Wisconsin
Badgers looking down from a huddle big
is beautiful is the headline did you
okay this did you give the checkmark
so the night no saying this one but it
does you know it's uh it's an it's an e
group and as long as they know that it
means nothing going forward guarantee
anything then you know good for them but
it's uh they get they get more they get
more attention here and they have had
four I've been lucky to be here for a
number of years and and the big guys
have always gotten pretty good love here
so mmm just better back it up yeah I was
about to say I was about to say cuz a
lot of offensive linemen don't usually
want the attention sometime you know i
remember the old broncos offensive line
just like they were they refused to talk
coach yeah and I kind of appreciate that
but it's the illest group works and and
I think they do have a good personality
and I don't think one guy alone would
want to talk but I think they feel kind
of together a little bit different but
it's you know you're happy for them but
they said and they know it it means
nothing and you got a you will get an
opportunity this year and what we make
of it's up to us and and you guys go
compete and you know in all those things
but it's uh I think they've they they've
got in a good balance I think well and
in that Sports Illustrated coach Chryst
an article was entitled Alex Hornibrook
SARM is the difference between a good
year in great year at Wisconsin what are
your thoughts on a headline like that
you know it's never life's never that
simple right but it's um you know Alex
I've appreciated and it's been fun to
kind of see his growth the last couple
years and
and he works at it and you know this
team is important to him and yet you
know what's great about the game of
football is it it isn't and it can't and
never will be one person and you know I
think that I was one of the best things
about last year is it took everyone and
you know recognition comes their way and
John potatoes an all-american but he's
not that without the o-line I don't
think the ol lion gets the recognition
they get if they don't have a back like
JT and the quarterback and on top of all
that you know a defense and so you know
Alex certainly the quarterbacks it's an
important position and and he will have
a big impact on our games but it'll
never fall just solely on him well when
you mentioned JT Jonathan Taylor having
broken Adrian Peterson's FBS freshman
rushing record what does what makes him
so special you know he's one you know
coach obvious speaking he's talented but
he's a he's a unbelievable worker and
he's got a great blend of confidence and
humility and and it's he's been fun to
see and even last year he's having a
good year and a really good year and how
he handled you know things outside the
game he's a he's a special guy and and
it was that that's been fun to see him
continue to grow not only on the field
but off the field well Chris Wisconsin
head coach here on the Rich Eisen show
how do you how do you keep the kids I
guess on an even keel I mean cover of
Sports Illustrated there's a lot of
folks that think you're making the
playoffs this year winning the big ten
thirteen and one last year how do you
how do you keep this feet planted on the
ground here you know I think it's just
you get them to understand appreciate
and be in the moment and and you know we
had a group you know two years ago all
the preseason talk was that you know may
not make a bowl
and you know I think rightfully so they
chose not to you know listen to that and
it is whatever we do and you you don't
try to be as prepared as you can and you
go out and compete every Saturday and
and so a lot of these guys have lived
that you can't have it one way and then
try to buy into it another year and and
everyone knows that with all due respect
to the experts none of that matters and
and we talk all the time that the the
best part of all this is when you get to
play the game and you know when you're
playing the game that's that's as fun as
it gets and it's not until the end that
you have a winner or a loser so if all
you're worried about was winning and
losing you'd miss the best part of the
best part of the game that's playing and
then it's the same with the season you
know seasons a it's a journey and you
want to enjoy each and every day of it
and so you know that's kind of how we've
approached it from the beginning so you
know why would we change the way we
approach and I don't think anyone's ever
had higher expectations needed it's
probably across the country you know
every team in that team room and coaches
I know for us that we've got and have
always had high expectations and then
yeah you get the chance to go out and
play the games and see what happens well
of course you know you're you're you
have a you've mentioned humility several
times here and you know you walk it and
talk it although I do have to say we
didn't notice at the end of the Orange
Bowl you might have had a particular
thought on the turnover chain of the
Miami Hurricanes yeah
I'm not real smart I'm I was talking to
myself I could have just said that in my
head so that was you were not saying
that's anybody in an on-set or the worst
part about it all is that I could have
just thought it to myself but it's
nothing I say proud of it but it's you
could have chosen a different body part
to mention as well with the turnover
chain just you know yeah and it was
really good when my mom was the first
one to tell me what happened is that
your mom wasn't one who told you that we
could not live but outside the locker
room my mom was the first one that
[Music]
little kid around the game of football
so yeah I know right
we're lip readers out there we can read
your lips I never know when you're on
you know you never know when you're on
hey would you want it would you be up
for getting rid of the conference
championship and then making sure that
Wisconsin place somebody like Ohio State
or Michigan State every year and what
you're not playing them this year
sometimes you don't play Michigan right
I mean would you be up for something
like that I mean I do I loved it
you know when I was in the Big Ten as a
player and as a coach you know when you
played everyone right but it's I I
understand and know how we got to all
this and and you know what I'm not gonna
be the one that'll decide and so you
embrace what's in front of you and I
felt like you know when you get a chance
to last years we've had the opportunity
to play in the Big Ten championship and
you know that every game is a playoff
game and and anytime you're gonna earn
the right to play one more game that's a
great thing and yet I do you know
there's a traditionalist I think in in
me to love that when you know you're
always gonna play you knew who your
conference was and you're gonna play and
you'd ever you'd play in their Stadium
they come to your stadium but you know
for a lot of reasons that it's no longer
that and so you just kind of embrace the
way it is right now and make the most of
it and it's it's actually pretty good
well if you had a choice would you and
well would you have an eighth team
playoff I know I'm talking for
traditionalists here but would you would
you go there I don't I really don't
spend any time to them my opinion
doesn't matter
sure the culture Wisconsin yeah I asked
me to vote on it so well if you did if
you did vote on I'd have to think about
it before I vote it and I haven't really
thought much about it so okay I think
that's Paul Chryst saying 18 Playoffs my
you know what that's what I felt like
we're in a playoff game
every game all last the whole season and
yet I get in there's always going to be
that odd one out right is you know
should they be could there be and it's I
think that people are trying to make it
the best they can at least I like to
think that coach appreciate the time
have a great season great Big Ten season
hopefully we'll catch each other down
the line during the season I'd love it
if you're up right back at you - that's
Paul Chryst Wisconsin head coach here in
the Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience